I would venture to guess I don't know
the data maybe you can
um let me know but the personal
political leaning of the group of people
who had a Wikipedia probably leans left
I would guess
so to me the question there is I mean
the same is true for Silicon Valley the
task for Silicon Valley is to create
platforms that are not politically
biased right even though there is a bias
for the engineers who create it and I
think I believe it's possible to do that
I you know there's kind of a conspiracy
theories that it somehow is impossible
and there's this whole conspiracy where
the left is controlling the song I think
I think Engineers for the most part one
to create platforms that are open and
unbiased that are that create all kinds
of perspective because that's super
exciting to have all kinds of
perspectives battle it out but yeah
still is there is there a degree to
which the personal political bias of the
editors might seep in in Silly Ways and
in big ways Silly Ways could be uh I
think hopefully I'm correct in saying
this but the right will call
it's a Democrat Party
and the left will call it the Democratic
party right yeah like subtle it always
hits my ear weird like are we children
here like we're like we're literally
taking words and like just jabbing at
each other like yeah I could I could
like capitalize a thing in a certain way
or I can like just just take a war to
mess with them that's a small way of how
you use words but you can also you know
have a a bigger way about uh about
beliefs about various perspectives on
political events and uh Hunter Biden's
laptop on how big of a story that is or
not I've been in the censorship of that
story is there not that kind of and then
there's these camps that take very
strong points and they construct big
narratives around that and they I mean
it's very sizable percent of the
population believes the two narratives
that compete with each other yeah I mean
it's
it's really interesting
um and it feels but I it's hard to judge
you know the The Sweep of History within
your own lifetime yeah but it feels like
it's gotten much worse uh that this idea
of two parallel universes
um where people kind of agree on certain
basic facts uh feels uh worse than it
used to be and I'm not sure if that's
true or if it just feels that way but I
also I'm not sure what the causes are I
think I I would lay a lot of the blame
um in in recent years
on
social media algorithms
um which reward clickbait headlines
which reward
uh tweets that go viral and they go
viral because they're cute and clever